tu es très bouleversée par le sida l'an
oui
t'as rien d'autre à dire non
on va regarder le sujet alors les
préservatifs vendus en europe sont
aujourd'hui tous différents si la
texture et l'épaisseur sont standardisés
au niveau mondial chaque pays a ses
dimensions propre un non sens pour
bruxelles et martin bachmann commissaire
européen chargé de préparer une
directive sur les produits médicaux à la
veille du grand marché de 93
il souhaite imposer une taille unique
pour tous les préservatifs distribués
dans la cee
3 ce qui est surtout important en fait
pour la communauté c'est de pouvoir
remporter le maximum de sécurité aux
utilisateurs
le préservatif est aujourd'hui
malheureusement l'unique instrument
gérer entre guillemets qui permet de
lutter efficacement contre le sida les
différents vient ministre de la santé
des pays membres de la communauté ont
confié un certain nombre de médecins en
europe bien ce projet donc ils ont fait
des études morphologiques au départ qui
nous ont permis est bien de savoir
attendre de critères liés comme je vous
disais à la taille
selon leurs premières conclusions les
dimensions pour un préservatif européen
sûr et efficace serait de 16 cm de long
et de 55 mm de diamètre des chiffres qui
ont provoqué un tollé parmi les pays
membres de l'asean les plus virulents
sont les italiens pour qu'ils les
experts ont vu trop large
leur diamètre idéal serait en effet de
54 millimètres au plus en cher à la
hausse
en revanche en allemagne en
grande-bretagne ou présomptueux de leur
anatomie
allemands et anglais proposent
respectivement 57 et 61 mm les français
comme les danois n'ont pas fait une
question de fierté nationale et semble
se rallier au projet de bruxelles tout
comme les fabricants de préservatifs
à ce moment nous avons nous sommes
obligés de
2 adhérez à d'énormes différences
nationales et bientôt on n'a qu'une
seule norme a appliqué sa facilité ça
facilite notre attache un sommet sur les
questions de santé en europe est prévue
en mai prochain au luxembourg il promet
d'être vif les ministres lorsqu'ils ont
souhaité une norme unique pour les
préservatifs afin de garantir la
sécurité des utilisateurs n'avaient pas
imaginé que la taille serait un critère
déterminant
et aujourd'hui il n'apprécie guère que
les différences anatomiques de leurs
concitoyens soit à la une
des préservatifs préservent de tout
de tout sauf de l'amour intense y aurait
une taille unique de préservatifs en
europe ace de l'info est de l'intox
judith à l'oreille de michèle et michel
à l'oreille de thierry
oui
béatrice à toi de jouer je pense que
c'est de l'intox tu pensé de l'intox
pourquoi sont pas un peu ridicule quand
même pour les tailles bon je pense que
c'est de l'intox ya pas de différence
entre man le vieux monsieur un peu j'ai
un bon moi je vois tous eu pour
l'instant la taxe bas nos amis m'ont dit
de l'ain font alors on va savoir tout de
suite
philippe guérin l'expert merci pour les
applaudissements et bien bravo c'était
de l'intox
bravo bravo d'un commentaire mon petit
philippe c'est de l'intox
il n'y a pas de véritable conflit sur
les capotes en europe
c'est une affaire entièrement montée par
la presse anglaise à scandale c'est tout
juste s'il ya eu discussion
au départ les italiens avaient proposé
comme norme 54 mm de largeur
mais quand à bruxelles on leur a
expliqué qu'il n'y avait que deux
tailles de capotes 52 mm pour la taille
européenne est un petit peu plus petit
pour la taille asiatiques
ils ont arrêté de discuter affaires
classées donc pour la longueur il n'ya
pas non plus de problème et ça c'est
beaucoup plus étonnant la norme est de
170 mm soit 17 cm 17 cm s'est pas
beaucoup ça mériterait de gueuler quand
même pour ça et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous
émettez un pouce bleus